su apodo era decir Alfred y era una de
las personas sin hogar más conocidas en
el mundo Megan naceré murió este sábado
en el aeropuerto de Oasis al Google
donde vivió más de 18 años allá todo el
mundo lo conocía cuando me lo dijeron se
me soltaron las lágrimas y medio penas
tenía su banquillo y era su casa tenía
todas sus pertenencias etcétera
me han nacer y era un refugiado político
iraní con 20 años se fue de su país en
búsqueda de su madre pero considerado
como un enemigo político nunca pudo
regresar sin papeles fue expulsado de
Alemania Reino Unido Italia
creo que nadie puede vivir 11 años en
una situación así he apelado a dos tres
cuatro gobiernos en esta situación soy
un caso único de inmigración
llegó al aeropuerto de París en 1988 con
43 años sin saber que se quedaría
vine de Bélgica pero no pude volver allí
en Francia se negaron a expedir el nuevo
estatus de refugiado político entonces
me quedé en tránsito a veces en
detención a veces fuera de detención
luego en el aeropuerto me liberaron
tenía un billete de avión a Londres pero
me negaron la entrada en 1999 Francia
finalmente le ofreció el estatus de
refugiado pero me harán nacer y decidió
quedarse en el aeropuerto recibía su
correo allí era seguido por un médico y
había ganado la confianza de los
trabajadores del Terminal
Mi destino ha sido ser aislado tanto
ayer como hoy inspiró la película la
terminal de Steven spielberg de 2004
protagonizada por Tom hanks algo que le
hizo ganar decenas de miles de dólares y
le permitió vivir unos años fuera del
aeropuerto pero hace unas semanas había
vuelto para terminar sus días allí